Cela m'a fait rencontrer
des bénévoles et des aides.
Par exemple, quand je préparais ma maîtrise de droit
à l'Université du Queen's, au Canada,
les détenus de la prison de Collins Bay ont accepté de m'aider.
Je leur ai donné un magnétophone, et de la sorte, ils m'ont enregistré de la lecture.
Comme m'a dit l'un d'entre eux,
« Ron, rassure-toi, on ne va pas se sauver. »
(Rires)
Mais réfléchissez-y. Ces hommes,
qui n'avaient pas eu autant de chance que moi dans leur éducation,
m'ont aidé à obtenir ma maitrise de droit
par leur aide dévouée.
J'ai continué, et je suis devenu professeur
à l'Université Monash de Melbourne,
et pendant ces 25 ans,
les magnétophones ont été tout pour moi.
En fait, dans mon bureau, en 1990,
je cumulais 30 kilomètres de bandes.
Les étudiants, ma famille, mes amis, tous me lisaient des textes.
Mme Lois Doery,
que j'ai plus tard fini par appeler ma mère adoptive,
a enregistré pour moi plusieurs milliers d'heures de lecture sur bande.
L'une des raisons pour lesquelles j'ai accepté de donner cette conférence aujourd'hui,
c'est que j'espérais que Lois serait là
pour que je puisse vous la présenter et la remercier publiquement.
Mais malheureusement sa santé ne lui a pas permis d'être parmi nous aujourd'hui.
Mais je te remercie maintenant, Lois, depuis cette estrade.
(Applaudissements)
J'ai eu mon premier ordinateur Apple, en 1984,
et je me suis dit :
« Ce machin a un écran de verre, aucun intérêt pour moi. »
A quel point est-ce que je me trompais !
En 1987, le même mois où naquit notre fils aîné Gerard,
j'ai eu mon premier ordinateur d'aveugle,
il est là, en fait.
Vous le voyez ?
Comme vous le voyez, il n'a pas de... Comment dites-vous... D'écran.
(Rires)
C'est un ordinateur aveugle.
C'est un Keynote Gold 84k,
le 84k signifie qu'il a 84 kilo-octets de mémoire.
(Rires)
Ne riez pas, il m'a coûté 4 000 dollars à l'époque. (Rires)
Je crois qu'il y a plus de mémoire dans ma montre.
Il a été inventé par Russell Smith, un inventeur passionné,
néo-zélandais, qui essayait d'aider les aveugles.
Hélas, il est mort dans un accident d'avion, en 2005,
mais il reste toujours présent dans mon cœur.
Ça voulait dire que, pour la première fois,
je pouvais relire ce que j'avais tapé.
Il avait un synthétiseur vocal.
J'avais co-écrit mon premier livre sur le droit du travail en 1979,
avec une machine à écrire, entièrement de mémoire.
Mais avec ça, je pouvais maintenant relire ce que j'avais écrit
et entrer dans le monde des ordinateurs,
même avec juste 84k de mémoire.
En 1974, le grand Ray Kurzweil, l'inventeur américain,
a travaillé à construire une machine qui scannerait les livres
et les lirait avec une voix synthétique.
Jusque là, la reconnaissance de texte
ne fonctionnait en général qu'avec une seule police de caractère,
mais en utilisant des scanners plats à transfert de charge
et des synthétiseurs vocaux,
il a construit une machine qui pouvait lire n'importe quelle police.
Sa machine, qui était aussi grosse qu'une machine à laver,
a été lancée le 13 janvier 1976 ;
j'ai eu ma première Kurzweil
en mars 1989, et ça m'a bluffé.
En septembre 1989,
le même mois où l'on m'a annoncé
que j'étais admis comme maître de conférence à l'Université Monash,
l'école de droit en a acquis une, et j'ai pu l'utiliser.
Pour la première fois, je pouvais lire ce que je voulais
en passant un livre au scanner,
je n'avais plus besoin d'être aimable avec les gens !
(Rires)
On ne me censurerait plus.
Par exemple, j'étais trop timide à l'époque,
et je le suis encore aujourd'hui, pour demander à qui que ce soit
de me lire à voix haute un texte sexuellement explicite.
(Rires)
Mais, désormais, je pouvais saisir un livre au milieu de la nuit, et... Vous voyez...
(Rires) (Applaudissements)
De nos jours, le lecteur Kurzweil se résume
à une simple application sur mon PC portable.
C'est dire à quel point ils l'ont miniaturisé.
Aujourd'hui je peux scanner le dernier roman
sans attendre qu'il ne sorte en livre audio.
Je peux être au même niveau d'information que mes amis.
Il y a beaucoup de gens qui m'ont aidé dans la vie,
et je n'ai jamais rencontré la plupart d'entre eux.
L'un d'entre eux est un autre inventeur américain, Ted Henter,
Ted était pilote de motos,
mais en 1978 il a perdu la vue dans un accident de voiture,
ce qui peut être catastrophique quand on conduit des motos.
Il s'est alors tourné vers le ski nautique,
et a été champion de ski nautique handisport.
En 1989, il a fait équipe avec Bill Joyce
pour développer un logiciel qui lirait à voix haute
ce qui s'affiche sur un écran d'ordinateur,
que cela provienne d'Internet, ou du disque dur de l'ordinateur.
Il s'appelle JAWS, Job Access With Speech [Logiciel pour Déficient Visuel],
et voici ce que cela donne :
(extrait d'une lecture par JAWS)
Ron McCallum : C'est très lent, non ?
(Rires)
Si je lisais comme ça, je tomberais endormi.
Je l'ai ralenti pour vous.
Je vais demander qu'on le passe à la vitesse où je le lis.
Est-ce qu'on peut passer celui-là ?
(extrait d'une lecture par JAWS)
(Rires)
RM : Vous savez, quand vous corrigez des copies,
vous préférez en venir à bout assez rapidement.
(Rires) (Applaudissements)
La technologie qui me fascinait en 1987
se trouve maintenant sur mon iPhone, comme sur le vôtre.
Mais vous savez, je trouve que lire avec des machines
est une activité très solitaire.
J'ai grandi avec une famille et des amis qui me faisaient la lecture,
et j'aimais la chaleur, la respiration,
et la proximité des gens qui me faisaient la lecture.
Vous aimez qu'on vous fasse la lecture ?
L'un de mes souvenirs les plus précieux
date de 1999, où Mary nous lisait aux enfants et à moi,
près de Manly Beach.
« Harry Potter et la Pierre Philosophale »
N'est-ce pas un super livre ?
J'aime toujours être près de quelqu'un qui me fait la lecture.
Mais je ne voudrais pas abandonner la technologie,
parce qu'elle m'a permis de vivre une vie formidable.
Bien sûr, les livres audio pour aveugles
existaient déjà avant cette technologie.
Après tout, le disque longue durée a été inventé
au début des années 30,
et maintenant on met des livres audio sur CD,
en utilisant un système d'accès numérique nommé DAISY.
Mais quand je lis avec une voix synthétique,
j'aime rentrer chez moi et lire un roman osé
avec une vraie voix.
Encore aujourd'hui, Il y a des barrières
qui nous arrêtent, nous les handicapés.
Beaucoup de sites web ne peuvent être lus avec JAWS
ni avec les autres technologies.
Les sites web sont souvent très visuels,
et ils contiennent tous ces graphiques
et boutons qui ne sont pas libellés.
C'est pourquoi le World Wide Web Consortium, ou W3C,
a développé des standards internationaux
pour l'Internet.
Nous voulons que tous les propriétaires de sites
rendent leurs sites compatibles, de façon à ce que nous,
les personnes non-voyantes, soyons mises sur un pied d’égalité.
Il y a d'autres barrières causées par nos lois.
Par exemple, l'Australie,
comme environ un tiers des pays de la planète,
a des exceptions au droit d'auteur qui permettent aux livres d'être transcrits en braille,
ou lus, pour nous autres les aveugles.
Mais ces livres ne peuvent pas franchir les frontières.
Par exemple, en Espagne,
il y a 100 000 livres disponibles en espagnol.
En Argentine, il y en a 50 000.
Dans les autres pays d'Amérique Latine,
il n'y en a que quelques milliers.
Mais il est illégal de transporter les livres
d'Espagne vers l'Amérique Latine.
Il y a des centaines de milliers de livres disponibles
aux Etats-Unis, en Grande-Bretagne, au Canada, en Australie, etc,
mais on ne peut pas les exporter dans les 60 pays de la planète
où l'anglais est la première ou la seconde langue.
Vous vous rappelez que je vous parlais d'Harry Potter.
Eh bien, comme on ne peut pas faire franchir les frontières aux livres,
on est obligé d'enregistrer des versions différentes
dans chaque pays anglophone :
la Grande-Bretagne, les Etats-Unis, le Canada, l'Australie,
et la Nouvelle-Zélande doivent chacun avoir
un enregistrement séparé d'Harry Potter.
C'est pourquoi, le mois prochain, au Maroc,
il y aura un colloque rassemblant tous les pays.
C'est quelque chose qu'un groupe de pays
ainsi que l'Union Mondiale des Aveugles, tentent de promouvoir,
un traité trans-frontalier, qui stipulera
que si des livres sont disponibles dans un pays en vertu des exceptions au droit d'auteur
et qu'un autre pays partage ces exceptions,
on puisse faire franchir les frontières à ces livres
et faire revivre les gens, en particulier dans les pays en voie de développement,
où les personnes aveugles n'ont pas de livres à lire.
Je veux que cela arrive.
(Applaudissements)
Ma vie a été extraordinaire,
grâce à mon mariage et à mes enfants,
et aux métiers intéressants que j'ai pu exercer,
que ce soit à l'école de droit de l'Université de Sydney,
où j'ai servi en tant doyen, durant un trimestre
ou aujourd'hui, quand je siège au Comité des Nations-Unies
pour les Droits des Personnes Handicapées, à Genève.
En vérité, j'ai eu beaucoup de chance.
Je me demande ce que le futur nous réserve.
La technologie fera encore des progrès,
mais je me souviens toujours de ma mère disant, il y a 60 ans,
« Rappelle-toi, chéri,
tu ne pourras jamais lire les textes avec les doigts. »
Je suis si heureux que les interactions entre des transcripteurs de braille,
des lecteurs bénévoles et des inventeurs passionnés,
aient permis à ce rêve de lecture de devenir réalité, pour moi,
comme pour les aveugles du monde entier.
Je voudrais remercier ma documentaliste, Hannah Martin,
qui fait défiler les diapos pour moi,
et ma femme, le Professeur Mary Crock, qui est la lumière de ma vie,
qui vient me chercher.
Je veux la remercier elle aussi.
Maintenant, je crois qu'il faut que je vous dise au revoir,
Dieu vous bénisse. Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)
Youpi ! (Applaudissements)
OK. OK. OK. OK. OK. (Applaudissements)